hello everyone and welcome back to some
rapid action unleashes yesterday we
played a nice game and in the end we we
didn't have enough time to deliver
Checkmate so unfortunately for us it was
a draw by insufficient material but also
it's because our opponent persevered and
defended well so in this one uh I will
try to play a little bit faster we'll
see how it goes sometimes um I I do
spend a bit too much time um uh
explaining the the positions but uh yeah
I I will focus on doing that on my
opponent's time so here uh our opponent
is never drawn so hopefully this one
does not end in a draw uh so let's let's
see what we can do uh we start with E4
as we usually do and our opponent goes
for D6 so probably it's going to be some
sort of a pit but no he goes for G6
right away sort of the modern he will
play A6 Knight F6 Bishop to G7 and we're
going to we're going to let's grab the
full Center let's grab the full Center
and see what
uh uh what comes uh what comes out of it
uh all right so he goes after the D4
Pawn we're going to defend it let's go
with uh let's go with Knight to Knight
to
D2 uh we're going to develop our light
Square Bishop Castle King side and maybe
even fetto our dark Square Bishop to
counter his dark Square Bishop so that
seems like a reasonable way to go about
it of course C5 uh we're going to defend
the the center with Pawn to C3
and at some point he will capture and uh
he will try to exert as much pressure as
possible on that D4 Pawn all right so he
goes after the E4 Pawn since uh the
Knight here is pinned we're going to
we're going to go Bishop to
D3 yeah seems like a reasonable way to
develop okay so putting pressure more
pressure on the pawn we're just going to
Castle here nothing
uh nothing really happening here and
he's going to Castle King side most
likely but he might also Play Bishop to
G4 yeah to put more pressure on this uh
Pawn here so I'm going to play Knight to
B3 as it comes with Tempo uh it does
give me another Defender for my D4 Pawn
he will play Queen to B6 probably to put
pressure on my king here and we're going
to defend the pawn one more
time uh with Bishop to E3 and uh yeah
next we if we defend our Bishop for
example we can even play D5 with a
double attack here so
yeah uh it's a it's it's a pretty fine
position for both of us okay so he goes
for this so now uh the question is do I
go for H3 and allow this trade should be
good for me I will have the advantage of
the bishop pair and also have my Bishop
defended or he goes back and then we can
just uh defend our Bishop or we don't
even have to do that uh we could even we
could even uh play something like Queen
to D2 which is a pretty standard Square
for the queen you have the queen and
Bishop on the same diagonal you can even
pressure the dark Square Bishop later on
so that's uh one way to do it okay so
let's play Queen to
D2 and uh yeah we don't have to worry
about captures since our Pawn is
defended twice here he might try
something like A5 A4 H but if he does
that we're faster so he does have to do
something about the D5 Pawn
push uh we'll see what we'll see what it
does and later on we can play Rook to C1
we have to the we have to decide where
the Rooks go uh always E1 and D1 are
great Square for your Rooks but as the C
file has been opened up I don't mind for
example yeah okay so he's not worried
about D5 why
not why isn't he worried about D5 that's
a very strange
move what are are we missing something
here really doesn't seem like we're
missing something
here yeah I don't know what uh what his
plan is
here yeah it is possible that our
opponents blunder from time to time uh
you know the blunders are not exclusive
to to when when I'm
playing uh but again okay so Queen
B4 uh yeah that's uh okay so he he has
to give up a piece and
uh yeah that's
nice what do we recapture with we can do
it with the Knight or with the bishop
I'm kind of thinking the bishop since I
also want to shift my Bishop here as now
we're up a piece so trading down is the
way to go yeah we can just put our put
our Bishop to C3 but we can also just
play Rook to
C1 Rook to C1
one
yeah okay so seems to be an okay so he
wants to play uh C4 if I play something
like Bishop to C3 he might play
C4 uh but uh even though it does seem
like a double attack I will be able to
play Bishop captures on F6 so yeah we
can also do it that way or we can just
play something like
uh something like Bishop to A6
nah okay how to how to take as much from
the position as
possible okay let's first ask him what
uh what does he do with the with the
light Square Bishop let's first ask him
that okay so he goes here and uh we're
going to we're going to try and trade
off the light Square Bishops no we're
not we don't want to hang the pawn
here so
uh yeah let's go here no we could ask
him to trade and we sort of double our
pawns here but it's perfectly fine then
we gain more control over the C4 square
and we can shift our Rooks over to the a
file yeah that also seems like a nice
idea but yeah then he can play
C4 I can capture
here
yeah it does look uh does look a bit
nasty yeah let's let's ask him to do
that or if he goes Bishop to D7 then he
no longer has access to the C4 square
and we can uh we can safely consolidate
even with Bishop to C4 as the pawn is
defended but then he can kick it away
with H6 so we'll still have to figure
out how to go about
this uh but yeah also I'm not I'm not
against Bishop to A6 followed by Bishop
to C3 also seems like a reasonable plan
sort of not allowing his Knights to move
because all of the trades now favor
me and uh yeah okay so of course he does
not want to trade we're just going
to we're going to get our Bishop over
here no we still can't do that
yeah he's being very tricky here he's
being very
tricky yeah let's get let's get rid of
our
Pawn
yeah if the if the if the D file opens
up he might have some action here with
his Rook but also I don't think it's
anything
relevant and if he moves the Knight I
can even play Bishop C4 if H6 we can
even play D6 even that is
possible yeah it's not easy it's not
easy playing a piece up what is this did
he just blunder another piece
what is
G4 um yeah okay okay so he he he does
get access to G3 if
uh if something like that is
played but yeah also should not be that
big of an
issue
yeah now it's uh time to go after the
Rook now it's time to go after the
Rook he can't really go here because
then we have this if he goes here then
we don't have to worry about the C4 Pawn
push if he goes here we can even go back
Bishop to
C4 uh but he can capture here so if he
moves The Rook to the B file for example
we can then play Bishop to to C3 which
sort of holds everything and while the
Knight is very nice on G3 I don't think
it's going to be that useful we can
simply attack it and if he goes here
then the Knight defends that so yeah I
mean there are there are so many good
moves here it's hard to uh to to find
that uh sweet sweet spot one all right
so he goes here uh now we're going to
put the bishop on C3 which means that
now we can even move the
Knight yeah we can even move the Knight
as the bishop now guards the B2 pawn and
all of the traits here will now go in
our favor if he kicks away the Knight
the E4 square is also very night nice
for our Knight yeah let's go here
okay uh we will have to play a little
bit
faster okay so he attacks the Knight
nothing nothing spectacular happening
there let's just defend it for the
moment and now G4 is a threat as the
Knight covers the G G3 Square
so okay he's uh still being very tricky
he's uh adamant about uh not not
resigning a piece down I I I I can
respect that as I very rarely
do uh so G4 is the threat he has to
figure out how to go about it probably
he plays something like uh captures an
E5
or yeah moving the bishop doesn't really
I mean it makes sense it just doesn't
uh improve his position that much like
D5 he he hangs the C5 Pawn if he goes
after my Bishop I can simply move the
bishop nothing to it like even D3 will
be fine controlling this
diagonal so once we avoid all of the
tactics that he might have in store for
us we're just going to enjoy our
position being a piece
up
okay so uh not easy to to find a useful
move for him here he will probably
figure something out but uh yeah uh
tackling G4 is definitely the way to
go okay so F5 that's how he will do
it
uh and we will react to that by
capturing simple simple as
that now the F5 square has been freed
for his Knight and we can just go for
trades captures captures and now if we
trade then uh yeah we do sort of weaken
our B Pawn but uh yeah that's
fine our B Pawn gets a little bit weak
uh nothing to it we'll just play B3 and
everything is nicely
defended so now we just have to figure
out how to make the most use of our
extra piece
probably REM maneuver it
somewhere yeah like maybe Knight C4 to
E3 then Bishop C4 check followed by
Knight to D5 yeah D5 would be an
excellent Square for this
Knight and okay he does have uh some
compensation for the for the piece he's
up a pawn but uh one Pawn for the piece
isn't very impressive okay so he goes
for uh he goes after the pawn we're just
going to defend it and uh any any G five
or E5 ideas are not
really a worry for us because we can
just trade everything is nicely defended
so now we go now we go for this maneuver
uh D5 is still not an option because
this hangs
uh actually have no idea what what he
could even try
here I have no idea what he could even
try he'll probably slow played with
something like H5 or King to G7 uh which
is what I would to do you know just to
wait for your opponent to make a silly
mistake as there are no uh yeah oh he
goes for
G5 that is uh absolutely
amazing yeah it's not that's um okay so
he goes for that we're going to
trade all the trades work uh work in our
favor and now if he tries to avoid the
trade we can just uh oh no we can't win
The Rook right away
uh because
uh yeah
okay we're going to go Knight F3 we're
going to threaten the the pawn
here yeah we do have to be a little bit
careful since uh Rook E2 might be an
issue for for uh us but uh yeah okay so
he defends uh he defends well
here um let's just go after no not like
that obviously yeah it's very
nice very
nice yeah this is actually a pretty good
move this is actually a pretty good
move yeah I will have to sell pin myself
uh just for a brief moment
here not for long just for a brief
moment since I can't uh go for for any
tricks here with uh with with this I
have to play G4 and King to G3 and then
we're we're
okay
let's go
G4 he puts his King on a dark Square
which is very
nice yeah I'm sort of getting the
feeling that uh yeah he definitely got a
lot more out of the position than I
should have
allowed ah but what are you going to
do yeah we have to go we have to play
like this and we have to bring our
Bishop to E2 uh in order to be able to
to remove the king from the defense of
the
Knight and then we can get our pieces
back into the game yeah he actually
played this very nicely he actually
played this very nicely his Bishop is is
really good
there yeah I sort of thought uh it would
be it would be easier that he would not
put so much resistance but uh he did
yeah now we can unpin
here yeah but still it's very hard to
unpin yeah we can we can do it like this
Rook E2 Rook E2 uh I allow him to
capture here but no that would be silly
yeah this would
be yeah we have to play King G3
first I have to play King G3 first now
the threat is Rook e
to since he will not be able to capture
the Knight we will just trade
here
okay but if he moves the king yeah it
does become a bit
uh odd for us we're going to have to
play something like this to be able to
unpin yeah he's posing a lot of problems
for us but uh yeah we will solve them it
just takes
time okay so he goes here uh does this
allow us to go for some tactics I think
it
does yeah he goes here and now we can
simply trade
down we can trade down fairly fairly
easily
here since uh the Knight is no longer
attacked and now we're just up a clean
piece we're going to play H4 and win the
game yeah okay so it took uh
it took some work but we got
there never drawn lives up to his
name or maybe he still draws this you
never know yeah okay he has to trade uh
he goes after my Bishop we're going to
uh we're just going to move it anywhere
doesn't really matter
where no anywhere but there obviously
wow wow genius genius
all right so we we still have to push
our
Pawn yeah let's go
here wow this uh was not the best yeah
okay now he just
uh yeah now he just outplayed me that's
that's pretty
sad that's pretty
sad
okay we're still winning this but uh
what a what a what perseverance by him I
mean absolutely
incredible so again not the best
execution but he really put up a lot of
resistance there so let's see let's see
just uh what what we could have done
better all right so
yeah uh so the immediate E5 obviously
the way to go here but as he's playing
this line I'm sure he knows uh how to
how to counter this uh but yeah if if
you want to play it yeah when your when
your opponent does something like this
you should play it so let's see what
happens here okay Bishop G4 okay this is
all perfectly fine fine fine fine
yeah yeah he blundered a piece there and
uh yeah you you see how uh when when
whenever I say you shouldn't resign
after you after you you know blunder a
piece in the beginning like that uh it
still requires a lot of precision so we
actually played this okay nothing wrong
with any of our moves yeah captures
captures yeah it's perfectly fine and
then where did we allow him all of this
counter playay that's the that's the
question okay B4 here yeah so silly of
me not to consider B4 I I basically
advocate for it in every game yeah okay
so perfectly fine okay so Knight to F3
allowed him uh unnecessary counter
playay yeah because he can't really go
for a rook lift with Bishop guarding E2
Rook F5 was the way to go yeah with this
Knight to F3 uh it's basically nearing
drawish territory it's not it's still
winning for white but you have to play a
lot of precise moves like G4 okay I play
Rook F2 uh King here yeah King here so
yeah King even King H2 but uh yeah now
I'm of course completely winning and
it's not an issue I played an entire
game okay wasn't the problem but uh here
you see such a uh you know a poor brain
moment where he got a completely winning
position but then he just uh uh allowed
this bishop to C4 move which I played
and then he even uh yeah went into this
uh and he disregarded that the bishop
guards the queen he could have continued
checking me and probably even uh
maybe uh outplay me on time as uh like I
said I don't really play all that all
that fast when I'm when I'm recording
these rapid games but uh yeah uh again
not the point of these videos the point
is to you know give you an an Insight in
in what to do you know in the in the
opening in the middle game especially
when you encounter a position you don't
know and when I'm playing I'm most of
the times encounter a position I don't
know since I don't I'm not really an
expert in opening Theory but yeah once
you know things get um really messy and
you have to figure out how to go about
it with a little time on the clock
that's where you're on your own and you
will have to outplay your opponents uh
of course try to try to do it much
better than than I do uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it uh
another another tricky one but even
though with with our poor play We're
actually doing okay I think um let me
just check uh I think uh yeah last game
okay we we drew but uh sorry about that
let me just check check
here yeah we were able to okay we we we
got a win in this one draw in the
previous one uh
sorry yeah yeah a win in this one draw
in the previous one then a win then a
win and then a loss okay out of the last
four games three wins in the draw uh not
that not that bad regarding uh you know
what weird stuff we are we are uh
pulling but uh yeah seems to be working
so uh yeah I I I will try to focus more
but it's just uh it's just not easy you
know trying to trying to give out your
thought process while calculating I
don't know it's probably the two sides
of the brain colliding the one you know
that um uses words and the one that uses
uh uh calculating power I have no idea
like even in bullet I don't play such
silly moves like I did with Bishop the G
Bishop the G1 here is really terrible
move uh but yeah I hope you're getting
something out of this these videos and
uh yeah if if you want to see something
else some other openings do is hashtag
suggestion and I will try to try to
deliver it at some point so once again
hope you enjoyed it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing with the coverage of
everything that's happening in the Chess
World and of course checking up on your
wonderful suggestions uh so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your
day